as women we are fed this lie that you
can have the super happy and productive
and like fulfilling life by just selling
your body it will not be that way you
look at the mental health of sex workers
you look at the mental health of you
know porn stars it's not good but when
you look at men and women men are
biologically designed to go so the seeds
there's a reason why you do not carry a
child for nine months for women it's
like I need to find this one specific
partner I can only be pregnant for nine
months and so with women there's a
reason why like biologically hook up
culture and just living with a bunch of
people it's like sex positive culture
for women I don't think it's healthy
because it's going against how I believe
we are literally biologically designed I
also think that porn is one of the
things that is destroying my generation